I want to talk about the English
language and why so many people in
Britain can't speak it this week the
format integrations are Dame Louise case
he said Britain should set a date for
everyone living here to be able to speak
English to help heal the growing problem
of segregation already I can hear the
liberal lefties screaming and this is
racist and disrespects particular
religions looking at your governments
and public institutions cannot fear
being demonized for trying to stamp out
segregation misogyny and patriarchy
people who want to live here and share
in Britain's fantastic spoilers must be
prepared to integrate they can't shut
themselves away in closed communities
taking what this country has to offer
but giving nothing back and if they
can't speak English they can't give
anything back
segregation leads to alienation and
that's dangerous but this isn't just
about migration in immigration it's
about equality for women particularly
Muslim women according to Dame Louise
many of whom who speak no English at all
so it's simple if you come here and you
refuse to learn our language you don't
get to stay it's actually lovely to have
you rejoined the side of feminism Karol
Pater against misogyny I'm enjoying that
you said so many people can't speak
English you know I have a couple of
stats for you so the number of people
who say they can't speak English well
it's 1.3 percent of society which a
number of people you're talking about
you can't speak English at all not point
336 there's now it's a lot of the Year
0.3% lot of people I see so the idea
that we're kind of in this society
stuffed full of people who can't speak
English which is what I kind of do you
care about the ones who come now I do
and on that I agree with you I think you
will not have equality of opportunity if
you can't speak English and that's why I
have been so critical of government
spending cuts to Esau which is English
speakers of other languages which has
been cut by more than a hundred million
pounds in recent years so my critique
view is not what you're saying per se
because I agree I think people need to
be able to speak English if they are to
thrive in this country my critique is
that instead of seeing this for what it
is which is a failure of leadership a
failure of government policy
it's virtual people's if it's some
negligence ability to learn to speak the
language it's arrogance respectful not
to speak it's our responsibility to have
services that allow we have them we have
them we try as ago 20 million I think
you're just my 20 million Carol they've
been cut by a hundred million now get
the fifty million this year so what is
it but you're so passionate about people
speaking English it's a lot really a
miscibility to see that you don't think
that something was possible therefore if
I was with you you lost me at they can't
give something back just because you
can't speak English you could be work
well you could be contributing to
society where I am totally with you and
I find the numbers that Beth was gone
through is quite interesting is if
you're living in this country which
hopefully we all agree is a great
country if you are going to benefit from
what this country offers it would seem
to me to make sense that you speak the
language I worry about and I don't
pretend to know but I hear about there
are areas in cities such as Blackburn
and and Bradford and other areas where I
am told that I've not been there
personally you just don't hear English
spoken I don't know that's particularly
healthy I also question the amount of
money that has to be spent by the NHS by
local courts and other services local
councils on interpretations and
interpreters for council leaflets if you
happen to be in Spain or you live in
France or you live in wherever it might
be Portugal everything comes through the
door and it's your responsibility so I
think there's a cost there all that
being said I don't cut and I think it's
very interesting what Dame Louise said
but what are you ultimately going to do
if you have for the purpose of debate a
little old lady living in Bolton who
just cannot and she's come from India
and she cannot get the level are you
honestly gonna say we're gonna kick her
out I mean this is this is clearly
something that affects my communities
directly and it affects me directly and
I was with you till you said a different
line and that was when you said if you
don't learn English you should leave go
home now the reason that affects me
personally I've made
like me to go so my mother speaks
English as well as all of us but my
stepmom my parents had divorced my
stepmom who my father remarried recently
wanted to with my father adopt a Syrian
refugee child because she can't have
children for herself and she was refused
because they told her that the foster
well sorry its fostering not adopting
and the foster caring services told her
that her English wasn't good enough and
so they refused a child so it's a back
eight years ago we at Quilliam issued a
report called triple paralysis and the
paralysis we looked at that was
discriminating against Pakistani and and
Bangladeshi South Asian Muslim British
women was threefold one they were Muslim
second they were immigrants and third
they were women yeah and so we found
that they were the most deprived
economically challenged economically in
the country they had the least social
mobility they were the least employed
and they were the group that spoke the
the least we always have low status
employment if they definitely something
needs to be done but on the cuts point
that aforementioned I agree because
actually if we have a look at this that
there has been a sixty percent funding
cut in real terms when it comes to
teaching English language and again
eight years ago we recommended the
government continue to spend on teaching
English English language because it's
the only way people like my stepmom can
actually learn what I wouldn't want to
do and I'm sure you'd agree with me
Carol is if she her English isn't good
enough to adopt a Syrian refugee child
I'm sure you wouldn't say that she
should be you in the order you say if
she's gonna go job to Syrian child she
has to engage with schools with local so
it makes absolute sense you shouldn't be
expelled for not being I'm speaking of
[ __ ] Majid why should the taxpayer pay
for your stepmom to learn English yeah
well actually the question the real
question there is is is actually our
deeper question as to whether when it
comes to these sorts of market failures
the taxpayer should step in or not
because actually if she could get work
she'd be paying taxes and would then pay
the taxpayer back but some was there is
an economic cause I would say get you
stepmom parent learning yourself
stretch out she helped we've identified
two problems one that there aren't there
isn't the availability of English
languages and English language lessons
because of the cuts but two there isn't
really the will on the part of those who
come to L in this country living in
segregated areas where they speak their
own language to go and learn English and
then their footing integrate that we've
got two problems which which are
actually contributing towards for
example item I would argue the Asian
grooming gang situation yes if you had
like for women if you have the women in
these families who are part of this part
of society and not sitting at home
amongst their own kind who actually grew
involved who could go to the authorities
speech the authorities about this you
wouldn't have these person let's let's
look at what a dame Louise Kathy has to
say about this English language is
absolutely vital it's our common
denominator it's what brings us all
together as a nation so I want more done
on English language skills I want more
opportunities for people in these areas
around employment we need you know
people out of low status employment like
taxis and chicken shops though they're
all useful but they need to have a
trajectory that goes further into life I
want more mixing opportunities for all
young people whether black-white
rich-poor Muslim non-muslim we all need
to mix with each other as we're growing
up that would make us a stronger and
healthier nation what dave louise also
says is that too many public
institutions in this country have spent
too much money making life too easy
people who can't speak English now let's
just give you some of the costs here for
translations Enbrel City Council's
translations included Kurdish Bedard
lease irani dialects all sorts of
dialects Crawley County Council paid 600
quid to have 12 lifestyle magazines
translated and English because one woman
who spoke only odoo complained about
it's just you have you have I think it's
Warwickshire County Council paid
hundreds of pounds to have a weight
boosting leaflet transferred into Punjab
you know you know then it's costing we
discussed in public services councils
who are on the verge of going bankrupt
companies cut in the one hundred and
fifty million quid a year
translation services stop that what we
said eight years ago is take the money
you save from stopping those translation
exercises and put them towards teaching
English language courses that's what we
said eight years what you're talking
about you're conflating so many things
and I and now you seem to be on the side
of not pushing councils to breaking
point financially which you weren't
necessarily when I raised austerity the
point is there are there's bad public
decision-making in councils to comfort
that's ridiculous
you know if the council squeeze that
calm provide basic services it shouldn't
be translating 12 lifestyle magazines
into a number of languages at the same
time I don't think you can blame
minority communities for bad decisions
made by local councils and I see this
whole question of English as a carrot
let me finish
you said the ten minutes of this whole
debate about people not being able to be
English I see this as a symptom and not
a cause we're talking about it as if
it's a cause the reason that they're not
integrated the reason they're not
employed is because they don't speak
English the reason they don't speak
English is because they're living in
segregated areas over characterized by
poverty lacking an opportunity we are
not talking of talking of the
consequences of poisonous language in
this case we've got to move on